this is the 2018 Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show the hour-long nationally
televised event has served as a showcase
for the brand's bras in lingerie since
2001 but 2018 was the fashion shows last
broadcast the show had suffered several
years of declining ratings that
coincided with a drastic rise than fall
of the stock price of Victoria's
Secret's parent company Elle brands
here's how the lingerie retailer angels
and all rose to the top of women's
fashion and how its fall from grace has
created an uncertain future for the
company in 1982 Elle brand owner Leslie
Wexner acquired Victoria's Secret a
small retailer consisting of six stores
and a catalogue for $1,000,000 Wexner
developed many successful retail
businesses in the 1980s and 90s he
popularized the specialty mall retailer
which had tightly focused product lines
and carefully designed stores and he
took those stores and rolled him out to
malls across the country that model
really upended the department store
model in the mid 90s Victoria's Secrets
heavily padded Miracle Bra designed to
create cleavage was vying for market
share with its competitor the Wonder Bra
only Victoria's Secret has the miracle
bra get a miracle bra Victoria's Secret
doubled down on ads with provocative TV
commercials and launched its first
fashion show in 1995 Victoria's Secret
tried to define what sexy was and what a
sexy woman should look like and you can
really see by the ads that they were
pushing a very specific Beauty ideal
that image was executed by Al Brands
chief marketing officer Edward Razik who
was put in charge of casting models for
the fashion show throughout the 2000s
Leslie Wexner sold many of his apparel
brands and focused more and more on his
lingerie in beauty lines
this included launching pink in 2004 a
Victoria Secret spin-off for teens
unlike many other retailers Victoria's
Secret continued to grow after the 2008
recession the retailer opened more
stores and sales expanded in Elle brands
stock price rose
until 2016 that's when you really
started to see trouble for the company
as consumer tastes started to shift
athleisure began to dominate fashion and
growth began to slow and Victoria's
Secret's bra business this was driven in
part by consumers preferring bra le'ts
bras with no underwire or padding there
was a shift in what female consumers
wanted from their underwear and what
they were willing to pay many younger
women didn't want to pay $60 anymore for
a padded bra that they saw on a
supermodel many of them preferred stuff
like more authentic marketing natural
looks and bras built for comfort in 2016
Leslie Wexner assumed direct control of
Victoria's Secret he eliminated swimwear
stopped mailing out catalogs and double
down on sports bras by 2018 Elle brand
share price had fallen 50% erasing about
fourteen billion dollars and investors
wealth Victoria's Secret started to
appear out of touch with female
consumers around the same time a major
stumbling block for Victoria's Secret
was when ad Razik told Vogue that he
didn't think transgender models should
be cast in the fashion show
he was forced to apologize for those
remarks and a lot of people called for
his resignation immediately he actually
stayed on a while after that and
eventually resigned in 2019 Victoria's
Secrets internal culture and management
has come under scrutiny as well ad Razik
after he left Victoria's Secret has
faced allegations of harassing models
and employees and les Wexner has come
under fire for his ties to Jeffrey
Epstein who was his longtime money
manager Leslie Wexner has said that he
cut ties with Epstein more than a decade
ago after Epstein was charged with child
sex trafficking independent directors on
the Elle brand's board responded to the
sexual harassment allegations in a
statement that said the company had
instituted robust anti-harassment
policies in recent years and the company
regrets any instance where we did not
achieve this objective of a safe
welcoming and empowering workplace Razik
told the New York Times that the
allegations were quote categorically
untrue misconstrued or taken out of
context consumers have a very particular
of what Victoria's Secret is it'll be
interesting to see whether a brand
that's married to such a particular type
of marketing can transform itself into
anything else
[Music]